ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono pa vj e oggi
siamo super che anima g0 che sarebbe il
videogioco visivo veramente chiesto
parimenti da quando è uscito in tutti
quanti di farlo quindi alla fine ragazzi
era destino che non rovesciate l'acqua
sul computer grazie perché stavo giusto
per grazie su perché arrivati da 0 a 100
del cane cane conca ragazzi gioco ancora
in fase di sviluppo quindi e lo dico che
stiamo per assistere a rob e prove ma
veramente roba comunque livello tutorial
proviamo questo perché ancora se l'ex
miglior personaggi facciamo cose cosa vi
voglio essere cosa cosa culo cane yogurt
offendere facciamo yogurt light john
corso all'inizio mi voglio sempre
desiderato essere cose nella vita mi
sveglio la mattina dico cazzo come
vorrei essere cosi un figo maglia volo
diver crombie di premi calata cosa so
che sei bello perché ti vesti da age
nelson leva cose resto so rever tutorial
solleviamo cose perfetto che poi è un
sasso ragazzi con la faccia però perché
c'ha la faccia un sasso tieni premuto il
tasto destro ho mangiato un sasso come
questa è una mela questa si mangia
miracle mouse
ok questa sì la pena mela la lanciamo
mentre il sasso mangiamolo perché mi
sembra ovvio
credo sia la cosa più bella alla quale
io abbia mai giocato nei primi cinque
secondi in cos'è sta roba
posso mangiarmi anche questo mangiamo
anche questo quanto zio possono
fracassati il pubblico ciglia se ce
l'hai non funziona la spada e tarocca
facili
no ma vero che figo posso dire
equipaggiare le mutande ma come ma sono
nude o 5 punti su culo 20 su piedi 20
sui muscoli che non li vedo però neanche
io me li vedo uno scrigno che ha una
faccia spiegatemi in senso
che cazzo veloce con le fette di salame
veloce lottatore del cazzo è sta roba
cos'è sono morto serve a farmi morire
cioè io come sta roba cade a terra
perfetto e cioè la cosa più utile della
storia c'è un nokia la chiave credo che
adesso io sia invincibile credo adesso
non ne sono sicura era un nokia fake
perché i nokia non si distruggono
neanche con l'acqua sentite non ho
capito bene ac un anno ho trovato un
altro nokia fermi potere del nokia agli
old eva stati se avessi usato un iphone
sarebbero morti
l'iphone grosso sarebbero morti tutti
quanti lo stesso è un box questo dai
daimon e morto morto mi ha lasciato un
piede posso lanciarti no sono cadute e
il piede affogherà ragazzi perché non so
se lo sapete ma i piedi non sanno
nuotare
voglio uscire un perfetto grazie credo
che la mia vita sia completa dopo questo
che i ragazzi per fare il salva i vol
che sarebbe difficile facciamo difficile
voglio essere il culo cane stavolta
[ __ ] tutto voglio scassare i culi
allora siamo partiti ti prego dimmi che
dormi qui e non qui zio di ti prego culo
cane lo so che ti inventi le cose però
tazza di caffè più 5 a piedi prendiamo
la tazza di caffè ha ovviamente dato
ragazzi la tazza di caffè mi fa fare
questo cosa sono questi cosi fermi che
ciò io ho una noce e la noce e letale
bastardo deve anche la crostata e l'età
non sottovalutare la crostata addio vedi
magari concreta e mezz'ora ago picchio o
la padella e dei cinesi o è una merda
non sono una dei doni va avanti potesse
contratto un piede ho vinto
[Musica]
non so mangiato guadagnato anche più 4
di vita non so come ho trovato un 7 non
è soltanto il numero più alto che esista
nella storia è anche l'unico numero che
esiste nella storia quindi se siete
morti se ve lo lancio proprio sei morto
a 7 morto la domanda più grande che mi
sto ponendo in questo preciso momento è
ma posso mangiare melo 7 posso mangiarmi
un 7 ho guadagnato anche più 3 limita
fantastico a cena a prato questo
fantastico affetto salve c'è un game boy
c'è un di eva ragazzi fermi no no no no
no no no il cazzo non posso farvi niente
devo mangiare gli e voi ragazzi l'ultima
speranza che ho che casa non si capisce
più un cazzo però in compenso sono salvo
c'è una crostata veloce dai che c'è poca
vita veloce ma già sono morto perché ho
mangiato una crostata ragazzi abbiamo
imparato che le crostate fanno male
quindi da domani se mangiate crostate
morite crepando velocissimo effetto odio
grazie a dio ce l'ananas ho lanciato un
nokia ragazzi ho rischiato l'apocalisse
perché c'era corona o cazzo
chi è questo mica quanta vita ti lanci
un cane la faccia di un cane stronzo sei
morto saranno perché mi fa paura più
degli altri però non si muove quindi
finché non si muove lancia anche un
piede qualche bravo a vela lezzi o cazzo
non scherzavo si muove siamo merda
chiedono lanciarli cose perché secondo
me mi fa il culo ecco questo è un boss
tipo blood work forza ho una voglia che
non avete idea di mangiarmi il cane solo
che ho paura del risultato però quindi
non lo faccio è il boss finale credo
dopo questo finito e vabbè mica quanta
gente c'è il nokia nokia nokia nolo
motion i 7.000 di merda
dai zio ma come fai ok che altro non so
perché la l'esplosione uscito un piede
rap a chia salame si è morto già fatta
non ci credo non ci credo ma ho vinto
veramente mi chiamava un uomo ammazzano
prima che arrivi al traguardo non ci
posso credere
e invece no ho vinto un [ __ ] pietre
ragazzi poveri ragazzi è stato
dall'altro prima di che ho fame non ai
capezzoli zio non meriti del cibo bruno
primo episodio su super chiara maci 0
legend of the cane cane non mi piace
perché lui ha fame ragazzi per ogni mi
piace una crostata in più se siete state
attenti avete capito che le crostate non
sono vostre amiche
chi volesse sopportare il gioco ragazzi
lascio il link del sito nella
descrizione del video è quindi ragazzi
se il video è piaciuto a settare
permetto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come david altra tana
descrizione questo video bisogna
lanciare almeno sette mi piace perché se
non sono sette
non va bene solo se dovessi discrezione
ci rivediamo non prossimo video belle
ragazze